just a few minutes outside today and you
could feel it it's disgusting I don't
like it with the wind chill it felt like
-30 even minus 40 in parts of Southern
Ontario this morning extending the
extreme cold weather alert in the city
and even layers were no match for the
biting wind and frigid temperatures I
got on two sweaters a t-shirt two pairs
of pants and lots of a Hooda do you
still feel cold oh freezing in Sub-Zero
weather like this it is not only bone
chilling it's also dangerous especially
for those experiencing homelessness four
warming centers remain open across
Toronto those locations combined have a
capacity of 142 spaces but the city
expanded that capacity to 195 spaces
overnight the city also added 432
shelter spaces to the 9 000 emergency
shelter spaces it was already operating
in addition to enhanced Street Outreach
prolonged exposure in such a deep freeze
can put you at risk of frostbite or
hypothermia in just a matter of minutes
for many who who didn't have to be
outside the walk was brisk and the
exposure to the elements brief I've lost
internal turtleneck sweater heavy duty
coat and here we are he says this is
Canada I do live in my time outside I
just walk to work and walked back to my
apartment because it's too cold to do
anything else Marianne domain Global
News